こんにちははじめ社長ですさあやって
まいりました味をしめてすぐ3階に行って
いますどこに行くかは分かりませんあなた
のお家に行くかもしれません日本ダンスの
旅
を指でやってまいりました第3弾でこの
企画どういう企画と言いますと私始め車窓
今からダーツを日本の地図に投げます
そして刺さったところどこだろうと今すぐ
ただつに向かうそんなアホみたいなダーツ
の旅です明日のことなど知りません今発生
やつなんですけども奇跡的に明日相手て
もうここでやるしかないと踊って十傑内に
も行ったんですけどまぁせっかくなという
ことでをロバが鳴りますねーほどスロー
夏菜に戻ってねしてもらえてだけでどうせ
だったらだが素朴に行きたいなと思って
やるん
やらせてくださいという月ダートの旅散財
3でございます1回目が新潟県の方に入っ
て2回目がヶ月 by さん結構すぐだ
から岡山県の方に行かせていただいたん
ですけども今回はどこになるのでしょうか
壁に貼ってある地図にダーツを投げるって
感じだったんですけど結構チューブより
日本のて頭の真ん中に行き掛けなきゃなと
思って今回さんを
ルーレット信じさせていただきますこれは
たルーレットダーツを統合したかわかん
ないんでこれに当たったところに言います
と医学でいただきますみなさんどこに住ん
でますかコメントに教えてくださいスフレ
0それはいけないね日本国内にとどまらせ
ていただきますただ本当に皆さんが住ん
でる所に行く可能性が今からありますので
ちょっと楽しみにしててください一
間まっそれやばいこれ山田
古来母
ああああああシュガーええええええ
[拍手]
やっぱさーわーないよね
もうその同意するが入っ
はいです
[音楽]
わーっわあああああ
love いやー一派っては東京でも食べ
るっ
そうておこう
おおおおう
中野だ
[音楽]
ブーブー言っ
なあーっ
にょ彼がまた守る日は打つな恋バナ違う汁
で今回はこれなんだ八ヶ岳聞いたこと有る
なんてものが近くの湖もありそうという
よりで長野県になりました
じゃあさっそく是永の下のどこら辺なんが
調べていきましょうよかった4つだけ
ささってたら山登りやっても
本当にピンポイントで言うと
ここらへんのネットの湖なるから死のう
しって言うな
ちょっと場所でいうとまずスってやっぱの
中です
絶対当たったのどう見てもガチでズームし
ても森のぞう方しか出てこないんですね
諏訪湖という一箱のスタート理科な場所と
しては長野県の諏訪市と茅野市の下あたり
ダーツでちゃんと当たったばする
ピンポイント作ってみたいと思います
たぶん森です
森かやまです
行ってきます
はいことで静岡から長野ということで結構
年に時間もかからないぐらいでつけると
いうわりと近い場所にありますラッキー
ですねこれはありがてロード a +
カッター
ピカいって
に景色じゃないよ
me
近い近い近いデー
なあねー
何な誓い
ぽって
地下ええええ
me
中野気入りました
いやいや天気よ
ケッ
というわけで団体がさ正確な場所ではない
んですけども近くの諏訪湖につけました
聞いたことあるよね聞いたことはあるまあ
結構まだ朝早いんでとりあえずちょっと湖
見ながら水辺金探索しつつもちょっと
朝ごはんだか何か食べればいいなって思い
ます
つけている
巻いてきた残す言うなよってわけで
まあセグで長野きたということでどうせ
だったらね中のでしか食べれないような的
な朝ごはん食べたらいいですね錯覚いき
ましょうかそれだけでつきましたこちら
お前のロードをすごくは何とか
おいでももねーよああああっ
ボイヤー
ただ
聞かないらしい
もう見るぞ
うわーなんかさ火来ないがそこだけで
あそこれ泳げるんじゃこれ
大あるじゃんビック言ってそこでそう
でしょ
5あそぼ5秒0
鯉山臼あんなとこ行ってこいよこれ誰もい
ないからもうなんでこんな観光スポット
などの概念遅いぞ
法廷があるぞおお
まあでも準備中だこういうところから行け
たりしないかなした使えていますかん
[音楽]
沈む積んどいてもヤバ
えっ
せっかく植えてくれてあるのにちょ
[拍手]
大丈夫かこれ遠いをこれ食べませんだ
次の街行っちゃうよこれこれ次の松レート
じゃない健康
行為ねこれちょっと防災したのことさ2行
伊豆道犬んん
[音楽]
スパ4でどうぞ
歩いて行けます o ただ一時間かかり
ます
[音楽]
ブーブープロパティ
いください
[音楽]
カツ
そこが出るの
なんてっあいつは何を目指してるのは将来
どこ向かったのが怖いんだけどなんか
[音楽]
eleanor なんとか登りのサービス
いればできましたでもさん見て確実にさー
すごくは近くなったわけですよ
ほらあの日コースター近く感じるよ
あれはリークなんか麻生スポーツ
日払った
何が ok な
をがメスちょっとさ美味しそうな
ソーセージがあったね回ましょうそれやっ
たぁー
[音楽]
きました
入ってます
はぁクリーム
また取られてるよ
おばあさん
お母さん
さあを目指していただきます
皆さんのと創生女優みんなのわかんない
けどどうなってありません
[音楽]
ん
ケチャップとマスタード nars しかし
に先約らも福田おい j もういいねん
なんか夏休みぽくなってきたん
虫ハブっぽく
ごめんちょっと寝不足でしょ
いやいいけど琵琶湖キレイだなぁ諏訪湖ね
ん
もうかっこいい
ほんと者らぼっち走行会それで回だけを
れる顔が見れちゃう a 広いよってぜ
可能な器が見えてないです花粉対策
いただきますじゃあこれ
うわーっ
me
どうしたんもうわー
めっちゃ組むするよねー
は行って面なぁ
これが艦これでた人だぞ
いやーすごいよ
[音楽]
[拍手]
よし母艦の
まぁちょっと総合見てから以降で本当に
立ったところは書きました
[音楽]
千影皆すごいよ
ってか全然客じゃねーじゃんまあ図書おり
れるよちゃんと思うすごいなんだ
誰が落ちるような風に出さないでえっ
それらもとか便で大丈夫ですやっそこの上
で二人矯正と番目であったかね
さあ負担など批判も食ってぶー
[音楽]
ワールドなぜさんに地下を構えてるの
おっキノコれていることだ食べてヤバ
were you
do 4
いい感じうんうんいい部屋とっていると
笑っちゃってるじゃんおっ思います
感じ可能わー
ああああああああああああ
[音楽]
ブーブー1巻4時が何なので切ってもらい
ました
これさっき家の上りのサービスエリアで
サーフィンからとってたターンズームで
浮いてたんだろうまずブータン少しかここ
は泳いで言うといやダメだと
ただ字幕の人が言うならダメだぜもと話し
たらいいんだからな
ねえ
左や意味でいいよああああああ幸せだ
らしいと言う時すごいねでも広いねー広い
[音楽]
ああああああ
[拍手]
すごい太ったら
まずでもやっ
弾くでしゅワークは無事楽しみたのでここ
からダーズで本当に刺さった場所に小さい
行ってみたいと思いますもう逃げですから
今折れちゃってる
[音楽]
にょ自転車さっところに行かなきゃ意味
ないんで閉めもないからたどたどしくしか
ない多分ここなので the ここで
セットします大谷これヤバイぞ人が行か
ないと殺す取れずいきましょう現代科学は
ああっ
進歩し続けている理由
なんで前期が命じる
[音楽]
あるんですかね
ソースの意地でもいいかと交通渋滞
なんで渋滞おけるんだこんな技術進歩せん
だけどね
バターは変わんねーと思ったスマイレある
ん
bl
はっはっはねぇ
うーん eran
まあメロンパンじゃないぞ
[音楽]
んおお
何番組バーガーブルー
[音楽]
あれ
ぽんぽんっ
すごいやみちですもうホモ1個道みたいな
場所ですなーところに向かうでしょうか
ったら2の急ぎは
[音楽]
where
はい中間皆さんランドの旅目的地到着し
ました
[音楽]
投稿
現在地がここになります完全にダーツで
当たった場所と同じ場所でて今そういう
わけでここねー
どこ
ポイントにどこコレ
ってか誰もいないからいい本当に入っ
ちゃった猫絵猫は勝てなかったら山の代金
の50%食べません
めっちゃ綺麗
アポロ探さまだ魚
羽屋羽屋どこどこどっ
だーけっけ心の綺麗な奴しか見えないんだ
あっはい大善名まずで温度大大大大大
でおら目のがたスペースを突くだって本当
に女にすっごい趣味あったってるよ
たから今更いるダメですよと坊
ああああああ立っています
やばい
入ってダイエットって太田インナーをかけ
てください
入ってるねありがとう
さあ
じゃない
あってやばいなぁだってとっていっ
[拍手]
ブービーよ
できないはいというわけで今回のターって
何度いかがでしたああ
楽しかったですねー
楽しかったね楽しま
者です
3年ちょっと今8月の中旬たからバチバチ
やっていいんだけど夏なのにめっちゃ釣れ
たカップいややっぱ川西コースですそうだ
な俺はそうは思わない4チャクラを取るか
の力チカロ
うわあああああ
良ければ先も来ました
いやーもう一ですねーどうせだったらの
長野の美味しい料理みたいないうかを知ら
の女な俺もある運気はもうあっちにも映る
太鼓ってお店ある交えたお幸せだ
えっおいしいとだめっちゃ薄いウール
だけで最後はもう田舎のでしか食べられ
ないようなおいしいごはん食べて帰り
ましょうね会えご飯行くぞ
dl
[音楽]